Democrats are officially impeaching
President Trump escalating to
unprecedented and historic Heights their
three-year crusade to overturn a
presidential election and subvert our
constitutional order have they finally
gone too far as the left threatens to
undermine our laws open our borders
steal our property destroy our
institutions and force taxpayers to fund
to the wholesale slaughter of infants
the stakes of the 2020 election become
clear the left wants a fight we will
examine the political merits of scorched
earth then Pete Budaj edge channels his
inner bado a New Jersey Democrat
politician defends the murder of Jews
and Supreme Court justice Neel Gorsuch
comes under fire for wishing someone a
Merry Christmas all that more I'm
Michael Knowles and this is the Michael
Noel's show
[Music]
they're doing it impeachment is
happening it's officially happening
today the Democrats have the votes they
will be able to impeach the president
this impeachment is a big deal I know it
seems like it is and I know it's so
ridiculous they've been trying to do it
for three years now we've kind of lost
interest in it this is a big deal
President Trump will be only the third
president in American history to be
impeached the third out of 45 presidents
he will be the first president to be
impeached without any reason whatsoever
without even the pretense of having
committed an impeachable offense the
Democrats dropped that there's no
bribery charge so it's just about
removing a guy that they don't like from
office this does not matter politically
right now this does not hurt Trump right
now Trump will be acquitted just as soon
as cocaine Mitch can snap his powdery
fingers he will be acquitted that we
will forget about this possibly within
weeks but historically this really
matters historically we are in a
position now where the constitutional
order the separation of powers might be
fundamentally broken historically we
might now be in a position where rather
than having three co-equal branches of
government the president the legislature
and the judiciary we may now be in a
situation in which the legislature the
Congress reigns supreme over the
executive and the executive is is
basically just serving at the pleasure
of the Congress a fundamental perversion
of our constitutional order that the
problem with impeachment here is not a
problem in the here-and-now that's why
Democrats think they can get away with
this and that it doesn't matter and they
can give a little bit of a little bit of
red meat to their base what matters here
is the historical question president
Trump knows that so Trump is speaking
out he just sent a letter to members of
Congress of course to Nancy Pelosi in
the Senate but also a letter to history
it's six pages long I
we'll give you just the highlights the
whole thing is a highlight but I will
give you just the the top highlights
first I've got to thank our friends over
at ring you know how important it is to
feel safe speaking of your loved ones
and your posterity this season can be a
whirlwind of deliveries visitors and
holiday travel so it's the best time of
year to upgrade your doorbell and keep
an eye on who is coming to your house
whether it's a guy delivering a package
from Amazon or whether it's your
mother-in-law coming over ring helps you
stay connected to your home from
anywhere so if there's a package
delivery or a surprise visitor you will
get an alert you will be able to see
hear and speak to them all from your
phone and it doesn't matter where you
are you could be in your bedroom you can
be in your office you can be on a beach
somewhere across the country you can be
going over the river and through the
woods to grandmother's house you will
still be able to check in on your home
it just makes you feel safe you know
sweet little lease is a pretty good shot
but still when I'm on the road I like to
know that she can feel safe as a
listener you have a special holiday
offer on a ring starter kit available
right now with a ring video doorbell too
and motion-activated floodlight camera
the starter kit has everything you need
to start building a ring of security
around your home no matter what this
holiday season brings you with ring
you're always home go to ring.com slash
Knolls cana wles that's ring comm slash
Knolls additional terms may apply so
Trump sent a letter he's Trump Unleashed
he's finally broken his somewhat silence
I don't never had a silence about this
issue but he hasn't been as public in
his opposition to the impeachment as you
might expect from a guy who tweets all
the time he sent a six-page letter for
historians even though the letter is
addressed to Nancy Pelosi here are the
highlights dear madam Speaker I write to
express my strongest and most powerful
protest against the partisan impeachment
crusade being pursued by the Democrats
in the House of Representatives this
impeachment represents an unprecedented
and unconstitutional abuse of power by
Democrat lawmakers unequaled in nearly
two and a half centuries of American
legislative history all true he goes on
by proceeding with you're invalid
impeachment you are violate
your oaths of office you are breaking
your allegiance to the Constitution and
you are declaring open war on American
democracy
you dare to invoke the founding fathers
in pursuit of this election
nullification scheme yet you're spiteful
actions display unfettered contempt for
America's Founding and your egregious
conduct threatens to destroy that which
our founders pledged their very lives to
build absolutely beautiful absolutely
right he goes on this is the money line
this is my favorite line of the entire
letter you are the ones interfering in
America's elections you are the ones
subverting America's democracy you are
the ones obstructing justice you are the
ones bringing pain and suffering to our
republic for your own selfish personal
political and partisan gain now he backs
this up he backs up this claim about
Democrats subverting the constitutional
order and just trying to get their own
political agenda across with no regard
for the Constitution he backs this up by
citing many examples of Democrats over
the past few years
simply pledging that they're gonna get
this guy out of office regardless of
whether he commits an impeachable
offense or not
here is a quick cut of this that the RNC
then put into an advertisement to come
out at the same time as the letter this
is about preventing a potentially
disastrous outcome from occurring next
year in posture he really should be
punished that's charlatan and the White
House
I'm not running for anything except the
impeachment of job we cannot accept a
second term for donate something if we
don't impeach this president he will get
reelected
[Music]
so that's what it's all about and we
know that's what it's all about Trump is
not trying to convince Democrats not to
be utter partisans to the detriment of
the country what he's trying to do in
this letter is show historians how wrong
this whole process was and and that's
what you get in his final paragraph he
grew that says he says it explicitly I
write this letter to you for the purpose
of history and to put my thoughts on a
permanent and indelible record 100 years
from now when people look back at this
affair I want them to understand it and
learn from it so that it can never
happen to another president again great
letter a great letter I think he's right
about the historical point I think in a
hundred years people will look back on
this impeachment as a truly shameful
period of American history either when
our constitutional order was sort of
irreparably sent down this broken path
or this path of no return
or it will be a moment when we all
reflect and say hmm we'd rather preserve
our constitutional order than push our
own partisan interests but this is a
real moment we've never seen something
like this before
we've seen impeachments too and a
process begun for Richard Nixon before
he resigned but only to impeachments
that the difference here is there's
really not even a pretense of having
committed an impeachable offense that
poses a fundamental risk to the way that
our government is structured you might
say that history won't look kindly on
Trump because of all the terrible awful
no-good rotten things he did it's very
difficult to figure out how history will
look in the heat of the moment because
we all have our partisan political
passions if you can just kind of cool
down your emotions about this I know I'm
preaching to the choir here but I know
that if the left could cool down their
emotions and historians look back on the
Trump era what are they going to see
they're gonna see a great
they're going to see in terms of
domestic policy a sort of moderate
Republican president they're going to
see a guy pulling back on our wars
overseas they're going to see a guy
getting tough on trade with some of our
trading partners or trading adversaries
they're gonna see a guy who was
impeached without having committed an
impeachable offense that is gonna look
pretty good for Trump it's gonna look
pretty bad for the Democrats I mean even
just consider george w bush george w
bush who had a fine couple terms in
office at the time everyone said he was
Hitler he was the worst president
American history was an idiot he was a
dolt he was evil he was terrible
now with the hindsight of ten years
people look back on him and say oh yeah
he was fine even Democrats look back and
say yeah he was fine whatever
imagine what history will say about
President Trump with this truly
unprecedented impeachment I love the
letter because it shows you the stakes
the left is pushing open borders full on
property confiscation taxpayer-funded
abortion the redefinition of biological
sex literally the redefinition of our
own nature and now be complete
undermining of our constitutional order
when you look at that when you look at
the stakes of that and you consider any
opposition you might still have to
President Trump as a conservative or a
centrist or a moderate or a libertarian
or any of those those philosophies
you've got to ask yourself who cares
about the tweets who cares who cares
what he said about John McCain who cares
what he said about Rosie O'Donnell who
cares about any of that nonsense you've
got the American left posing a
fundamental danger to our constitutional
order and you've got a loudmouth reality
TV host who's actually been a pretty
good president that's not a tough choice
for me and I don't think that's a tough
choice for a lot of Americans where some
people see only risk only threat only
danger in this impeachment I got to tell
you I see some great opportunity we will
get to that opportunity in a second
first I got to thank our friends over at
honey you know this time of year
you got to try to get the best deals
because you're buying gifts for
everybody it's hard online the prices
are fluctuating all the time
that's where honey comes in honey is a
free browser extension that
automatically finds the best promo codes
whenever you shop online automatically
so you're always getting the best deals
without even trying on over 20,000 sites
such as Amazon Target Best Buy all the
top sites more honey has found over 10
million members over a billion dollars
worth of savings I've been using honey
since before the daily wire even existed
all right I've heard about this from
some techie friends of mine and I I i am
certainly among the hundred thousand
people who have positively reviewed this
given 5 star reviews on the google
chrome store i don't know that i could
tell you the last time i used honey
because I always use honey I was using
honey just last night when I was buying
last-minute Christmas gifts if you're
buying gifts this season then you need
honey if you're not you probably know
someone who is so do masala tel in bed
honey takes two clicks to install you're
gonna love it
right now it is free it installs them
two clicks get it at join honey calm
slash Knowles Cana wles
that is join honey calm slash Knowles in
this impeachment where some people are
seeing only risk only danger I'm seeing
some opportunity it's a great
opportunity never let a crisis go to
waste
as Rahm Emanuel says so for the past few
weeks few months we've been debating
what is conservatism what are we here
for what are we conserving what do we
stand for the libertarians and the
traditionalists and the religious right
and the neoconservatives of populous
what do we all stand for together people
accuse us of only opposing the left they
say the only thing that unites all the
disparate factions among the
conservative movement is triggering the
libs that's pretty much all we want to
do maybe that's not such a bad thing
maybe opposing the left is actually
enough to unite all the disparate
factions on the right people forget this
because we look back at history through
rose-colored glasses because nostalgia
is history after a few drinks we think
that the conservative move
from World War two until the fall of the
Berlin Wall that that was some pure
amazing movement that had no problems
with it and it had an affirmative plan
and I love Bill Buckley and Ronald
Reagan as much as the next guy but that
entire conservative movement that
persisted for the second half of the
twentieth century or more was based on
opposition to communism that's all that
it was about that's how united the net
national security guys and the
libertarians and the traditionalist
types the religious right to is by
saying we oppose communism the
libertarians opposed communism because
it was collectivistic the social
conservatives opposed communism because
it was atheistic we all came together
even though those groups didn't have a
whole lot in common we opposed godless
communism we wanted to trigger the
International lives and now that that
same impulse is is bringing us together
the same impulse that gave us fusion ISM
and the post-war conservative movement
is keeping this Trump era conservative
movement together
all right the left accidentally has
given conservatives a reason to unite
nowhere do we see this more clearly than
impeachment when they ask us what do you
stand for I don't know we stand for not
letting men into the little girl's room
we stand for not killing a million
babies a year we stand for not stealing
all of our property we stand for not
completely shredding our Constitution
that's enough for me all right maybe it
doesn't fit beautifully on some
manifesto somewhere maybe you can't sum
it up in a one-sentence log line but I
oppose all of those things I want to
conserve our American traditions our
American Republic that's what I want to
conserve and if the only way that I'm
gonna unite all the various groups that
have interests here is to oppose the
left good enough for me
Nancy Pelosi makes a fine villain Nancy
Pelosi is a good enough reason for us
all to come together if they are gonna
throw out a president because they don't
like how the election went there they're
not willing to play fair and square in
an election year no less we're we're
what 15 days from an election from
entering into an election year now but
they can't wait for that because they
know if they don't impeach Trump he
might very likely get reelected there
or still some Republicans who haven't
gotten the message I know it's hard to
believe that there are still like four
never ever ever Trump conservatives out
there it's not a big deal these kinds of
cranks have always been around there was
an op-ed published in the New York Times
just yesterday of course it was in The
New York Times called we are Republicans
and we want Trump defeated this is
supposed to be some shocking message
even the Republicans are breaking rank
with Trump this was written by George
Conway Kellyanne Conway's overgrown
child
I guess she's technically married to him
Steve Schmidt he's an old McCain Romney
type John Weaver who actually worked
with on a presidential campaign a number
of years ago but he's also very moderate
Republican who's worked for Democrats
and Rick Wilson another another squishy
Republican so four rhinos basically I
mean for Republicans who aren't that
kind of Republican for Republicans who
never want to be identified as such they
write this piece in the New York Times
which is the mouthpiece for the left and
they say we need the president to be
defeated the president and his enablers
have replaced conservatism with an empty
faith led by a bogus prophet oh the
great conservatism capital M with a
trademark over the e they've replaced
that glorious ideology with pretty much
the same thing they replaced the
conservative movement that opposed
international communism with a
conservative movement that opposes
leftism more broadly all right whatever
it seems about the same to me then they
write a bunch of nonsense and they talk
about why we're not gonna vote for Trump
I mentioned this not to give this
terrible op-ed any airtime I mention it
because The Times and the left and these
never Trump Republicans want to make it
seem as though this is unprecedented
this is courageous this has never
happened before this happens every
election I remember back all the way to
Barry Goldwater in the 60s you had some
squishy fake Republican going on TV for
Democrats and saying look I'm a
Republican but I could never vote for
Barry Goldwater do we have it I think
it's a commercial called confession
of a Republican I don't know just why
they wanted to call this a confession I
think they don't feel guilty about being
a Republican I've always been a
Republican
my father is his father was the whole
family's Republican family I voted for
Dwight Eisenhower the first time I ever
voted I voted for Nixon the last time
but when we come to Senator Goldwater
now it seems to me we're up against a
very different kind of a man this man
scuse me now maybe I'm wrong a friend of
mine has said to me listen just because
a man sounds a little irresponsible
during a campaign doesn't mean he's
going to act irresponsibly you know that
theory that the White House makes the
man I don't buy that you know what I
think makes a president I mean aside
from his judgment his experience are the
men behind him his his his advisers the
cabinet and so many men with strange
ideas are working for Goldwater there it
is I mean you could replace that guy
with George Conway you could replace the
word Goldwater with Trump you'd get the
exact same commercial this always
happens every year there are some squish
defectors who like being a conservative
or a Republican in theory but they're so
afraid of contradicting the prevailing
liberal leftist culture and they don't
want to lose friends at their parties in
Washington DC in New York and LA and
they don't actually care about affecting
the country all that much they just you
know they want to be respectable and
they were nice suits and ties and they
have fancy glasses and they sit in their
chair a certain way and they say I'm a
Republican but not that kind of
Republican I mean it's interesting to
note that this sort of phenomenon in the
modern era began with Barry Goldwater
because Barry Goldwater was pushed as a
conservative candidate explicitly this
was right at the beginning of the
conservative movement the Bill Buckley
National Review post-war conservative
movement and you had all these liberal
publicans like John Lindsay and Nelson
Rockefeller and Dwight Eisenhower and
then you finally had some conservatives
who stood for a different view what
Phyllis Schlafly called
a choice not an echo wasn't just
Democrat and Democrat Lite but you had
Democrat and conservative Republican and
that's when the squishes come out and
you're seeing the exact same thing here
you're seeing Republicans like these
guys George Conway Steve Schmidt
Republicans nominally who work for
squishy Republicans who work for
Republican but not that kind of
Republican who work for Republicans were
no more than democrat light and you get
this guy Trump and for some reason Trump
in particular really seems to earth them
you know what that tells us about Trump
it tells us that despite all of the
commentary to the contrary despite
everything we've heard from the former
gatekeepers of the Republican Party and
movement conservatism Trump is actually
pretty conservative much more
conservative than any of the guys who
wrote that op-ed much more willing to
fight for the things that once at least
United the conservative movement then
any of the guys who wrote that op-ed we
are up against a clear political
adversary a lunatic destructive
aggressive left all those other
conversations are academic okay the the
left must be defeated I'm channeling my
inner Cato the Elder the Roman Republic
politician who said Carthago delenda
asked in my opinion carthage must be
destroyed the left must be destroyed the
left delenda est our opponents oppose
everything we stand for now look our
opponents are our countrymen
I'm not saying we got to hate these guys
I'm not saying we should be angry and
furious at these guys but I'm saying we
must stop them they cannot succeed if
they succeed we don't have our country
anymore we'll have something else but
it's it's not something that I'm here to
live in that I'm eager to possess I want
to consider
of our country our Constitution our
dignity of life not killing a million
babies a year our own human nature the
the very definition of sex itself our
property I don't want people to come in
and steal my property willy-nilly our
separation of powers our federal
government
I want to conserve that and that's the
battle right now and if you're upset
because orange man said it mean tweet or
he one time made fun of Rosie O'Donnell
or John McCain or he I don't know use
tariffs as a tool in a trade war and
that's too much for you that's the line
I will not cross then you should really
rethink your priorities if you say well
Trump doesn't stand for anything I think
he does I think it's pretty clear that
he does he's been a very successful
president but let's say you didn't I
don't care right
it is simply enough for if I've got a
choice of two candidates one candidate
has a completely internally consistent
leftist worldview and they want to
undermine everything that I want to see
in politics and then you've got a
candidate who has this kind of
hodgepodge of a political ideology and
maybe some of it doesn't make sense
together but I know that at least he's
gonna try to stop the other guy from
doing the things the other guy wants to
do that's enough for me okay I'm more
than happy to take what I can get
politics is not the realm of the perfect
politics is not some abstract concept
where it's just floating in mid-air and
we can have philosophical purity and
everything works out great and we can't
get our hands dirty politics is a real
science it is a practical science and it
is the art of inclusion as the New
Jersey Governor Tom Kane famously said
you got to bring a lot of people
together Bill Buckley did this
incredibly effectively in the post-war
conservative movement Ronald Reagan did
this incredibly effectively and they
didn't whine and complain and moan and
say Oh what are we all really stand for
why can't we all agree perfectly why
can't we have a perfect doctrinaire
manifesto of the five bullet points of
conservatism that we all 100% agree to
why do we have to have Ronald Reagan
leading this he's a divorced kind of
former liberal
who didn't even go to the right schools
or work in the right think tanks and he
doesn't doesn't even necessarily wear
the right tithes he's kind of a
Hollywood guy oh how embarrassing for us
that's not who we are
that's not what we stand for give me a
break
you know it's it's sort of ironic
because all these guys who are coming
after Trump and the people who support
Trump guys like that in that New York
Times op-ed they're saying that we're
somehow betraying the conservative
movement of Bill Buckley and Ronald
Reagan the the opposite is true
Buckley Reagan Goldwater those were
these are practical guys they did
something that many thought was not
possible and they did it by bringing
people together who didn't exactly agree
with each other ideologically but they
knew they had a common foe that needed
to be defeated that's exactly what we're
seeing today and the ones who don't have
the stomach for it the ones that don't
have thick enough skin for it the ones
who don't have the vision for it whine
and complain but they are not the heirs
to the great successes of conservatives
in American history we are and we have
to keep pushing that victory just to
drive this point home because I think
maybe some people think I'm being
hyperbolic about it our opponents so
oppose what we believe as American
conservatives they refuse even to speak
English I'm not even just talking about
bado I'm talking about Pete Buddha judge
pedo pedo Oh Buddha judge and Chuck
Schumer and other leading Democrats
we'll get to that in a second first I
got to thank our friends over at quip
the quip electronic toothbrush it comes
in SuperDuper handy whether you're at
home or whether you're on the road they
make an incredibly sleek cool toothbrush
and it helps you stick to a healthy
brushing habit I used to be a cheapskate
I used to use those regular old manual
toothbrushes it's like brushing your
teeth with a stick doesn't do a whole
lot
my dentist finally tells me I need to
use an electric toothbrush quips
electric toothbrush has sensitive sonic
vibrations with a built-in timer and
30-second pulses to guide a full and
even clean it claims you two
so much better it makes it easy to stick
to this healthy brushing habit you can
start with the electric toothbrush then
you get refillable floss you get anti
cavity toothpaste it's great the quip
floss dispenser comes with a pre-marked
string to help you use just enough so
you don't end up with like reams of
floss that you're not gonna use quip
delivers a fresh brush head floss and
toothpaste to your door every three
months with free shipping makes your
routine so easy join the over three
million healthy mouths and get quipped
today you can do that for just $25 go to
get quip comm / michael mi CH AE l go
there right now you'll get your first
refill free first refill free it get
quick calm / michael GE t qu IP comm /
mi CH AE l quip the good habits company
our opponents so oppose what we believe
that they refused even to speak in
English you remember this from the
debates just a little just a little
reminder to take you down memory lane
persona en el éxito de este año mia pero
si quiere Moses eras necesitamos in
queer character Sona in nuestro
democracia cada Volta caca de votante
necesitamos la representación de cada
vez necesitamos escuchar the situation
situation our aura is inacceptable s de
Presidente are at Otago demon asado los
immigrant faces inacceptable a voyeur
can be arrested Okita carry of telling
el primero de su terry appreciators
arrested realidad
itself yonder what would you do
congressman day one a tewara vamos a
tratar de personas con el respeto Deena
dark a medicine c'mon Manos de amo
estoy pasando Presidente de los Estados
Unidos Ola Ola back everybody
this wasn't just at the debates that
this is going on boo de jedge who was
ostensibly the moderate guy in the race
is jumping on this train - he just
tweeted out yesterday El Pueblo UNIDO
llaman Sarah ven sido which means the
people United will never be defeated as
a radical leftist slogan today I'm proud
to announce a bold comprehensive plan to
dismantle the institutional barriers
that have kept Latinos from feeling like
they fully belong in their country
hey here's one of those barriers not
speaking English how about the people
speaking English will feel like their
home at this country how obviously the
pandering is pathetic the pandering is
so transparent but probably the number
one issue that keeps Latinos from
feeling like they're welcome in America
is when they speak a different language
it's very hard to feel welcome if you
don't understand what everyone else in
the country is speaking what they're
saying and the move from the left to not
just to discourage assimilation and
discourage learning English which is
pretty new Barack Obama told people to
learn English when they got to this
country and that was ten years ago
eleven years ago when it was actually
doing it more recently he was doing it
as latest 2014-2015 when you've got now
Democratic presidential candidates not
only discouraging learning English but
actually speaking horrible absolutely
even decipherable Spanish themselves you
have gotten to a level of radicalism
that is truly boggling to the mind and
it's not just Buddha jej who's doing it
it's humor too and it's by the way this
problem is not just at the federal level
the radical left ISM is at the state and
local level a seattle seattle agency to
deal with the homeless just use taxpayer
money to to sponsor a drag queen strip
show at one of its events New Jersey
school board member is defend
a recent racist attack on Jews there is
a lot of radicalism here we'll get to
that in a second first listen up I'm
going to save you time and money this
Christmas season the perfect gift for
your loved ones is what you know it's so
obvious a daily wired gift membership
from now until January 1st all insider
plus gift memberships will be 25% off
that means that your loved one will get
all the fantastic perks plus the
majestic important necessary leftist
ears tumblr you will get the savings go
to daily wire.com slash gift to get your
25% off that is daily wire.com slash
gift to get 25% off 25% off all insider
plus gift memberships this Christmas
season give them a gift they will thank
you for all year long the a wire comm
we'll be right back with a lot more
it's not just bait oh poor bait oh you
remember bait oh I barely do it's not
just bait oh it's not just Cory Booker
I guess he's technically still in the
race probably not for that long it's not
just Peabody judge even Chuck Schumer
yesterday was tweeting out in Spanish
for just no reason at all
that's pretty divisive language forms
the basis of our politics because
politics is just how we all live
together and persuade one another
to live in society if you don't speak
the same language that becomes
impossible and and even now Chuck
Schumer the Senate Minority Leader is
encouraging this sort of division in the
country we're not seeing this radicalism
only at the federal level down in
Seattle Seattle has this horrific
homeless crisis going on right now a lot
of cities do my own City does la San
Francisco obviously New York it's
getting worse DC it's getting worse so
the crisis of homelessness in Seattle is
not getting any better and an agency
which has the job of tackling this
homeless issue just recently spent
taxpayer dollars on a strip show
not just any strip show a transgender
strip show the transgender performer
Beyonce black st. James so this is a guy
who now identifies as a woman recently
stripped at the all home conference in
South Seattle for a group of homeless
advocates because that's what they need
they don't need food they don't need
help from addiction they don't need
psychiatric counseling these homeless
people you know what's really been
keeping them on the streets and keeping
them down on their luck they haven't
seen enough transsexual strip shows and
so the taxpayer money from Seattle is
now being spent to give them this
important form of entertainment I think
it's just what they need to lift their
spirits lift their lot in this world and
get off the streets right just
unfortunately for some reason we
actually have video of this we actually
have a clip just give this a listen
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so now what we're seeing
III don't even want to describe it I
don't want if you are just listening to
this right now I I think you're probably
better off whatever you're imagining is
definitely better than what I am looking
at I had not seen this video before and
I hope that I never have to see it again
that is unimaginable five years ago
we're not like we're prudes or anything
here okay we're not clutching our pearls
it's just simply a fact that taxpayer
money being sent on transsexual strip
shows would be unfathomable five years
ago and yet here we are do you oppose
that okay you oppose that then you're
with the Conservatives okay I don't care
your specific views on tariffs I don't
care your specific views on religion I
don't care for this political question
whether you go to church every week I
don't care if you think the government
should do this or that or the other
thing on some other question do you
oppose that that kind of radicalism then
you're with us that's that's pretty much
the message of the conservative movement
today and by the way it was the message
of the conservative movement even 40
years ago it's not just up in Seattle at
the level of East Coast local politics a
New Jersey school board member Democrat
just recently came out to defend the
assailants who murdered a number of Jews
at a kosher supermarket last week
Joan Terrell page as a New Jersey school
board member she posted this on Facebook
where was all this faith in Hope when
black homeowners were threatened
intimidated and harassed by I want to
buy your house brutes of the Jewish
community they brazenly came on the
property of Ward F black home owners and
waived bags of money resistance was met
with more threats of we will bring drug
dealers and prostitutes to live next
door to you you will sell to us then
was the faith and hope mr and ms and
these are the names of the people who
went shot up this market they went
directly the kosher supermarket I
believe they knew they would come out in
body bags what is the message they were
sending are we brave enough to explore
the answer to their message are we brave
enough to stop the assault on the black
communities of America my people deserve
respect and deserve to live in peace in
this city that is as clear a defense of
these two cold-blooded killers one of
whom at least was a black Hebrew
Israelite one of it was a black
supremacist member who went into this
kosher supermarket killed a bunch of
Jews that's a defense of that how much
of that story have you heard about have
you read about if you pay attention to
conservative media you've probably heard
about it if you're watching the
network's if you're watching CNN MSNBC
probably you haven't heard a whole lot
about that because they won't deal with
that kind of radicalism you know at
least the right when we've got these
really obvious bigoted awful people we
deal with them ourselves the left does
not do that so much to put the little
cherry on top of this this radical
Sunday in the media the left can't even
tolerate that Supreme Court justice Neil
Gorsuch wished someone a Merry Christmas
on television Supreme Court justice Neil
Gorsuch good morning to you Merry
Christmas Merry Christmas I love that
you say that what an honor to talk to
you Merry Christmas thanks it's nice to
say that merry Christmas to you here's
the response from the left from Sean
Kent who's a blue checkmark leftist on
Twitter on Fox News Neil Gorsuch made a
point to say Merry Christmas like he
just gained the freedom to say it under
Trump this guy is such a worst case
scenario of a stolen Supreme Court seat
worst case scenario Christmas Christmas
is the worst case scenario for this
leftist just a little historical tidbit
by the way you know who else considered
Christmas to be the worst case scenario
the devil that's who another leftist on
Twitter has hundreds of thousands of
followers
ami Vanderpool tweeted out quote Supreme
Court justice Neil Gorsuch just appeared
on Fox & Friends this morning making a
point to parrot the merry christmas'
talking point of the GOP merry christmas
is now a GOP talking point according to
mainstream leftists if he's willing to
go on fox and throw a shout out to
republican narratives what else is he
willing to do Republican narratives
Merry Christmas is a Republican
narrative now that used to be kind of
the basic thing that would unite us all
okay even if we disagreed over tax rates
or something at least you could all wish
each other a Merry Christmas now Merry
Christmas total right wing talking point
now the logical conclusion of that by
the way is that if conservatives lose if
the left gets their way there's no more
Merry Christmas
it's funny because this this woman Amy
Vanderpool is actually legitimating the
war on Christmas narrative so often the
left says there is no such thing as a
war on Christmas even though obviously
there is they rename Christmas trees
holiday trees corporate America bans the
word Christmas from their Christmas
sales and their Christmas marketing
Starbucks gets rid of anything that he
might in any way invoke Christmas on
their coffee cups a few years ago then
they learn that lesson they brought some
of it back obviously there's a war on
Christmas they usually deny it now
they're not denying it Amy Vanderpool is
saying yeah Merry Christmas
is a Republican talking point I hate
that a Supreme Court justice said Merry
Christmas on television this is a worst
case scenario and Merry Christmas is a
Republican narrative all right I guess
there is a war on Christmas the thing is
the best part the silver lining if there
is a war on Christmas we're winning it
and we can see the celebrations of that
when Eric truf won a president from sons
went on Jeanine Pirro show on Fox News
and they all sort of celebrated this
they all kind of laughed and enjoyed the
fact that in terms of the war on
Christmas Christmas is winning Eric and
I were talking about what's going on
with impeachment and the FISA and all
that
will you guys be able to just forget
about all of it and really enjoy the
fact that you really are part of the
first family you are the first family I
mean you you've done wonderful things
for this country we now don't have the
political correctness that we used to
and people are actually saying Merry
Christmas you can say Merry Christmas
yes isn't that so nice to me I love it I
love Christmas trees I love Santa over a
year I mean you know how do you feel
that your your father has done all of
that our it's incredible it is nice to
say Merry Christmas again it is it is it
was discouraged for a while
you don't need to take my word for this
is not some right-wing conspiracy
municipalities cities were actually
renaming Christmas trees to be holiday
trees what holiday there's only one
holiday that you have a tree for around
in December 25th but it the Christmas
became the holiday that must not be
named for a long time and then so much
of the reason from was elected is
because people were fed up with
political correctness now we're winning
and I think we forget this sometimes we
forget that in 2016 Trump and one we're
forgetting that now over the past couple
years
Christmas won the war on christmas
christmas is coming back around we
forget that we got our judges we forgot
that we got our tax rates we forgot that
the majority of Americans oppose
impeachment and removal from office we
are winning we're winning
obviously we won in 2016 but winning on
the impeachment polls we win by opposing
open borders we win on restricting
abortion we win I'm not letting men into
the girls changing room not letting men
beat women at high school track of
minutes we win on all of these issues
despite the mainstream media's
insistence otherwise despite the
constant negative press cough fa to
quote the president this actually helps
us and there's so much hand wringing
over how we unite again how do
conservatives unite again like we used
to in the good old days
it's the same answer is how we united
back in the 20th century we have to
unite because we can
afford to lose good argument to me and
it's pretty motivating as we look into
the future at the 2020 election that is
our show
come back tomorrow we'll have a whole
lot more get your mailbag questions then
we will answer all of them in the
meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael nul show see you there
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by Ben
Davies director Mike joiner executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey supervising producer
Mathis Glover and Robert Sterling our
technical producer is Austin Stephens
assistant director hovel Woodhouse key
editor and associate producer Danny
D'Amico audio mixer Robin Fenderson hair
and makeup Jeshua alvera production
assistant McKenna waters the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19 on the Matt
Walsh show we're not just discussing
politics we're talking culture faith
family all of the things that are really
important to you so come join the
conversation
you